welcome back to New Rockstar's Greta
gerwig's Barbie trailer drop Tuesday and
if you're big fans of the break room
then you know everyone here at new
rockstars is super excited for this
movie Barbie's Dreamland gets a whole
other meaning in this movie and it's
just so fun it's so pink I love it I'm
so happy but there has to be more than
meets the eye right maybe Barbie's
having an accidental crisis like the
rest of us regardless we're going to get
fully into this beach off and fan girl
as Barbie babes do and I bet you're
wondering who are those Barbie babes
well it's none other than myself and my
favorite Ken Tommy Vector hi I'm Ken and
I'm going through something come on
Jessica let's go party I'm scared though
the trailer is short there's a lot to
talk about we've gotten two different
film synopsis is two different film
synopsises online one saying Margot
Robbie's Barbie is expelled from Barbie
land and another telling us to live in a
Barbie land is to be a perfect being in
a perfect place which is not real unless
you have a full-on existential crisis or
you're a Ken both tell me Barbie will
spend most of this movie searching for
herself in something bigger so we'll
start by laying out the Easter eggs you
might have missed and then analyzing
what they could mean for the Barbie
movie all right we start off with a
barbified Warner Brothers emblem and
it's better this way then we get a
glimpse of the beautiful Barbie land
perfectly protected by a heart and a
pink airplane flying over it I will know
it's not the toy Barbie airplane I have
bought that for my niece that thing's
more like a cargo jet take note on how
beautiful and cute Barbie land is but
the real world surrounding it is dull
and less vibrant it's giving me don't
worry darling Vibes it's yeah it's
weirdly creepy but I still want to live
there I don't care we get a little clax
from Barbie's pink pumps on the pink
linoleum floor and when she steps out of
her little shoe her little Barbie foot
stays arched and she's just a genuine
doll and I love it so much she is oh and
then we get a couple more nod to the
Barbie toys we get a great view of the
beach and all that inhabitants The
Umbrellas resemble the one from Barbie's
Glam Pool we got an ice cream shop that
genuinely looks like Barbie's soda shop
but back in the day melted with the
Barbie ice cream truck set and a roller
disco along with a disco 59 club we know
Barbies love to party don't we
I also love that this place is so
plastic the Barbie doesn't really leave
Footprints in the Sand if you only see
Zero sets of footprints in the sand it's
because we're freaking flying baby that
water doesn't even move the flags look
like they're swaying in the wind but
they're not everything is plastic
wrapped in plastic it's fantastic oh my
God just like me yeah and everything
transitions with a light like a very
light ding noise in between every little
cut
hi Barbie this beach is covered in cans
and Barbies and we learn from most of
the promotional material everyone is a
Ken or a Barbie unless they're Midge or
Alan or just humans which we'll come
back to so don't worry about it if there
was ever a woman that taught me to
accessorize it's absolutely without a
doubt Barbie sun and Beach Barbie is
always sporting a different necklace but
the late 90s one sports a seashell
necklace kind of like the one she's
wearing right now how are you gonna have
a beach Barbie not wear shells it's just
offensive you have to put shells on her
that's right when we see Ken play by
Ryan Gosling we start playing Barbie
sounds which must be the sweet sweet
sounds of the Beach Boys Fun Fun
like a full-on assimilation I'm just
saying it just feels like we're gonna
get brainwashed in a second it sure does
Barbie
sorry the aggressiveness
when she begins to say hi to all the
Barbie she waves to Alexandra's ship as
author Barbie and in front of her book
is a Barbie laptop Emma Mackie plays the
Barbie with a Nobel Prize in physics
Issa Ray is President Barbie once
simulus Ken waves to Margot Robbie's
Barbie it makes Ryan Gosling's Ken
insanely jealous and I gotta be honest
simu come on the break room stop wait
Barbie slides down her classic pink
Barbie slide I love the floaties in the
pool and one is a B I need that for my
pool personally keep in mind she's fully
dressed about the land in fake water
nothing is real here Jessica nothing is
real and I still want to live there I
don't care when Barbie cruises down the
pink brick road we see perfect hair
which I assume isn't a salon shop for
the plastic hair candy store and it's
spelled
c-a-n-d-i-e playoff candy of course but
candy is also one of the pups from a
Barbie collection we passed the Barbie
theater and is playing Wizard of Oz with
the posters of Dorothy Tin Man and the
lion we also pass Bax which I assume is
a playoff LAX because it's an airport no
one should ever replicate LAX it's a
hellscape don't fly into it fly into
Burbank yes remember Saturday mornings
the weekly holiday where you'd celebrate
by watching cartoons and eating cereal
their back baby thinks the magic spoons
magic spoons is the cereal reinvented
it's a high protein zero sugar cereal
that tastes awesome no matter when
you're eating it where you're eating it
or what cartoons are on at that moment I
eat these every day I eat this for
breakfast because I'm keto magic spoons
variety pack comes with four delicious
flavors they got cocoa fruity frosted
and peanut butter this is the peanut
butter this is the cocoa this is the
fruity and this is the Frosted also
aren't they just really cute each flavor
has zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams
of protein and four to five net grams of
carbs in each serving with only 140
calories per serving this is great they
are very keto friendly gluten-free grain
free and soy free this is amazing
personally I'm a sucker for magic
spoon's birthday cake flavor but I'm
going to devour this peanut butter
flavor because I didn't even know they
had it so I'm gonna go crazy yes it
tastes like I have no homework to do no
chores to do and nothing to worry about
but whether to sit on the couch or
sprawl out on the family room floor and
just eat click the link below to get
some magic spoon cereal today you can
build your very own variety box and
choose from the best-selling cocoa
fruity frosted or peanut butter cinnamon
roll and so many others and to celebrate
magic spoon's birthday in April they're
offering a free box of their fan
favorite birthday cake with any order
use a special link in the description to
make sure that the free box is added to
your cart this offer will only be valid
for a limited time so don't wait don't
waste your time get the cereal magic
spoon is so confident in their product
it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason they'll refund you your money
no questions asked and if you're in
Canada or the UK okay no worries magic
spoon ships there too everybody can be
keto so use the special link
magicspoon.com rockstarsb day to get a
free box of birthday cake with your
order
Ken changes into so many different
outfits in one trailer he genuinely
reminds us of the Ken from Toy Story
which I think was voiced by Michael
Keaton in this scene he's wearing a
glitter blue canned tracksuit we see the
choreographed dancing that was in the
small teaser trailer earlier and
everyone around them is choreographed
but Barbie because she's the center of
attention now in the first teaser might
have got a glimpse of this fight scene
but it's all the Ken's charging at one
another it's a Ken off they're using
juggling pins lacrosse sticks inflatable
Rings all those great accessories plus
the kids are all dressed like it's the
70s I love the Vintage and the back left
we see the pink Statue of Liberty make
my Liberty pink make everything pink
I'll take it I'll take it all we see
President Barbie holding some sort of
Bill they're signing something the color
schemes here again are amazing and the
flags all have pink shells in the B
Crest I'm just in love with these colors
and the contrast with them and the other
Barbies it's just so it's so beautiful
I'm obsessed with it we've got the
Supreme Court Barbie author Barbie and I
don't know who the other two Barbies are
just yet but one of them has a
prosthetic arm and we just love
inclusivity here because especially in
the Barbie Brands they're always
expanding and they're getting everybody
involved yeah make one with no hats you
cowards it looks like we're getting some
Espionage as well that's Ariana
Greenblatt America Ferrara and in the
back is Michael Sarah Alexander ship and
Margot Robbie from promotional material
we know that Greenblatt and Ferrara are
both humans
yes okay my personal favorite part of
this trailer Kate McKinnon's Barbie is
doing the splits and I think she's the
unhinged Barbie that was drawn on yeah
the haircut was tortured by a sadistic
kid always thrown around in different
positions I'm looking at you my sister
Teresa you called her out but I'm
ashamed to say that I was also the girl
that cut her Barbie's hair I think this
is such an inside joke because you would
cut the hair and then you just throw
them all over the place and that's why
you find them doing the splits and doing
weird stuff but yes Kate McKinnon's
Barbie is one of my favorite Barbies and
I should I should be honest it wasn't my
sister Teresa it was my sister Danielle
she's the evil one president Barbie must
have held the phone with her pink gavel
but what's interesting to me is the
Barbies are all dancing dressed the same
and the Ken Flags behind them is this
ultimately a Ken Dynasty Ken the
Conqueror Ken the Conqueror
Barbie looks at the mirror without a
reflection it's just a hole but look at
the giant size Barbie accessories the
perfume the brush it's all huge like
true Barbie accessories they're always
massive and barely fit in their hands
get them bigger brushes going back to
inclusivity bottom left you see Barbie
in a wheelchair watering her Barbie
plants we got our Cowboy Barbie we saw
in the leaked photos earlier there's a
cowboy Ken out there somewhere we just
don't see him in this shot but also this
is when Will Farrell comes in with who I
assume are his subordinates Connors
Wendell and Jamie dimitro look how
excited Will Ferrell is I like his
poster says call me mother yes oh my God
the Cannons look like
look like thing rock paper
probably a dance scene we know shimulu
mentioned taking dance classes again for
this role so we're excited for those
musical numbers yes uh please hire me if
you're feeling a little disoriented or
scared by now you should because it's
been playing The Beach Boys Fun Fun Fun
like a broken record
[Music]
I think it was done on purpose to
reaffirm this place is heaven on Earth
you should assimilate obey consume obey
consume regardless this place can't be
too bad if they're allowed to leave I
assume I miss it I'm just saying they're
allowed to leave they're leaving the
real world this way sign points to the
dusty desert we also have the pink
Warner Brothers water tower in the
corner oh I wonder if there's pink
Animaniacs I also love Ken's Barbie
style jumpsuit I wonder if when you
leave it's like partying a different
dimension which is why Barbie's car
flipped upside down after leaving Barbie
land huh additionally her license plate
says Barbie because if you didn't know
who she was that'll help genuinely I
don't think any Barbie cars have license
plates if I'm remembering no I don't
think I ever had one with a license
plate well you know what I'm gonna get
you a Barbie car with a Barbie license
plate don't worry Ken pulls out thank
God we don't want any little Barbies
running around I'm walking away okay so
we see Ken pull out the rollerblades we
saw in those leaked photos Barbie also
has the same matching pair we love a
matching rollerblade situation then we
get the Barbie logo the font is the
classic Barbie font over the history of
like the Barbie fawns they have changed
a lot but this looks closer to the 70s
font that was used from 75 to 91 which
makes sense for all the 70s iconic
styles that we've already seen in this
trailer yes then in a straight up jump
scare we see Michael Sarah who does not
age and he's playing Alan Ellen is a
real Barbie doll and Michael Sarah is a
human Barbie doll and he's dressed like
him too he's Ken's buddy he could be his
lover oh we will get into it later I
don't think they love him there I mean
they love it you can't I mean listen
smash two Tupperware containers together
you get it same diff there's other real
life dolls like Midge who appeared first
in 1963 but revamped in 2013. she's
Barbie's best friend there were times
she was and wasn't pregnant but this
Midge is definitely pregnant and who's
the father and who's the father is it
Alan it's me now I want to get into
what's happening in this movie what all
those Easter eggs could mean I think our
Barbie Margot Robbie is the main Barbie
character even in her own world whether
it's good or a bad thing during the
dance sequence she's the only one not
following choreography she's the only
one driving on the road through town and
during the voting stuff she's not there
this Is a Wonderland yes it's it's
Barbie's land reminiscent of Barbie's
Dreamland but this is all fake there's
more to it the Ken Banners are held high
above all the women dressed in pink
jumpsuits the kids are fighting on the
beach and every single Barbie had to
leave and from promotional material we
know Barbies are insanely talented and
the cans are just Ken's there's rumors
that Will Ferrell is the CEO of Mattel
and he even said his character is
insensitive and weird what does he do
that's insensitive and weird overall I
believe that Barbie definitely was
expelled from Barbie land and something
in Barbie landed isn't adding up and
she's the only one questioning it when
she leaves she finds the real world and
how much worse it could be but once
Barbie finds the humans along the way
she instills her Barbie wisdom on them
and I just love everything about this
movie already I'm very into the hyper
feminine world at play but it's still
framed under the male gaze and we
shouldn't forget that and it begs the
question how much problems are the Kens
of the world making for the Barbie
probably a lot yeah all of it and I
think we'll dive into the lore of Barbie
patriarchies and it will mirror the real
world closer than we think I hate the
cans I do
listen I'll be honest with you I grew up
with two sisters and a mom that were
obsessed with Barbie so as much as I'd
like to admit I was playing with Mr
Freeze and Batman all the time I was
playing with Skipper Mitch in the gang
okay I'm an OG Barbie man I used to make
him kiss I used to kiss them a little
bit take us home Jessica uh that's it
for our breakdown and Easter egg video
for the Barbie movie let us know how you
feel about the trailer in the comments
follow me at Lulu underscore Clements
follow the Tommy at Tommy talked about
those Barbie kisses follow new rock
stars subscribe to rockstars for more
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye come on Jessica we're
going to a party uh but you're the sad
one
[Music]
thank you